I have two kids you have two kids no
your kids my kids are seven and four my
daughter just turned seven okay I just
brought we brought this up on the show
earlier I mentioned that I in my in a
perfect world I don't even want my kids
to know that I'm I'm a comedian or on
television you know I just like that
they wouldn't even know that what about
you do your kids know that you're a
comic I must know first of all my kids
know I'm a big deal they very they're
very aware I don't know every day I said
look that is a big deal yeah that's your
version of the talk with your kids come
here sit down
no you know what man my kids are they're
very well you're not talking to me no
I'm a comedian it's funny because they
understand it like they've been in my
show so they understand daddy's job is
to make people laugh like literally they
get it and my daughter my daughter think
I'm funny though she doesn't she doesn't
think you're funny it's promise you
swear see my daughter does not think I'm
funny like literally she challenges me
like dad I don't I don't really think
you're funny I saw you on TV I didn't
laugh and I was like I'm funny I argue
like you're laughing I actually argue
like you you have no idea how funny
daddy is like I like daddy I'll do
something now and I can kill you with
jokes like I'll lay you out with
laughter she's like all right we'll do
it
so like you want me to perform cuz I
will she's like yeah I was like all
right I said introduce me so you know
she act like she brought me to the stage
and I hit her with a bit like a good one
like you know one of my best ones all
right what do they say about this and I
hit her with it she's like I don't I
don't like that when I said okay so you
want the good stuff so I hit her with
another one and she booed me like for
real
your daughter she had me three kid like
boobs like boo whoa and even though
she's a kid I got mad yeah
I swear to you we were talking about I
got mad like she was sitting our little
chair and like the legs aren't sturdy so
I kicked one of the legs that's just
good parenting I'd be a good thing to do
in comedy clubs to get rickety chairs do
you use you give you you sometimes
you're not afraid to to give your kids a
hard time right now
no no no I tease my kids I'm big on that
like my kids have big heads I tell them
every day like dude your heads are huge
disgusting like it's so disgusting ugly
but here's the thing his thing I say it
before anybody else does see that's
that's part of my parenting I'm
preparing my kids yes what other people
are gonna say you're not gonna hit my
kids with something and getting like
getting a reaction because they've heard
it all from me there's nothing you can
say there's nothing like sometimes my
son doesn't Bay they might do you dirty
like it's disgusting he's like what oh
my god I gotta call you dirty he's like
well that's one thing but saying they
have giant heads it's the truth
so true it's what it's what's known as
pre bullies I'm preparing them right for
the actual thought of someone bullying
them is it look don't judge without
doing my household I'm a big deal okay